in this video we'll talk about the
terminal
deoxynucleotidal transferase mediated
Nick n labeling method or tunnel assay
it's a mouthful of term but it's very
easy to understand the tunnel assay is
an analytical method to determine the
status of apoptosis in a tissue or cell
line
it utilizes the tdt enzyme or terminal
deoxynucleotidal transfer is enzyme
which can incorporate a labeled
nucleotide in a space of DNA damage or
where wherever there is a DNA break it
would incorporate a modified nucleotide
and generally these kind of DNA breaks
are found in apoptotic cell so simply
this kind of analytical method utilize
the principle of DNA breaks which
generally occurs in the late phase of
apoptosis so if a cell is undergoing
apoptosis there would be double stranded
as well as the single stranded DNA
bricks so let us understand in this
context how tunnel assay works
so when we add this enzyme the tdt
enzyme which is generally found in
several immune cells and required for
the vdj recombination it can actually
incorporate specific nucleotides at the
three prime hydroxyl open ends
so this nucleotide which is incorporated
it can be let's say a liberal nucleotide
a fluorescently level nucleotide or
let's say a biotin labeled nucleotide
which can be later on detected by
fluorescently labeled streptavidine
also it can be a brdu so brdu can be
detected by anti-brdu fluorescent
conjugate antibodies
so this is how the overall tunnel assay
work the labeling might be different but
the principle of the assay is same
detection
with the help of any kind of
fluorescence method and in this
particular assay the tdt enzyme holds
the key importance
now anyway the cells has to be
visualized under the microscope and has
to be co-labeled with the nucleus marker
dappy so here blue is dappy and green is
the tunnel staining so it's basically a
488
nanometer wavelength labeling so
anything which is green should be
indicative of tunnel positiveness so
this is a tunnel positive cells this is
a tunnel negative cell so tunnel
negative cells are healthy tunnel
positive cells are inferred as apoptotic
cell let us try to understand with help
of an example we have a cancer cell line
where we have treated with vehicle and
in other set we have treated with a drug
X Plus vehicle we wanted to understand
where the drug X can fight cancer and
can kill these cancer cells in order to
understand that we need a assay for
apoptosis or an assay for increased cell
death tunnel acid could be an
appropriate assay it is quick easy
performable and its readout is pretty
clean
so in that case we have to understand
over time how the number of tunnel
positive cells has increased or
decreased so if there is an increase in
tunnel positive cells that would be
indicative of more apoptosis another way
to put look at this data is to count the
percentage viable cells all the tunnel
negative cells would be the viable cells
so obviously if this drug is potent and
able to kill cells
that are Cancers so there would be less
viable cell over time and this is how we
can utilize Channel assay to determine
apoptosis now there are several pros and
cons of this technique for example it is
very quick so that staining procedure is
a fairly simple experimental cost is low
and it has reliable outcome but the cons
are tunnel assay is not programmed to
understand the magnitude of DNA damage
in a single cell
there could be immense amount of DNA
damage or could be less amount of DNA
damage tunnel stain give us a yes or no
type answer but doesn't tell anything
about the magnitude it cannot also
report the late stage of apoptosis or it
can only report the late stage of
apoptosis not the initiation phase of
the apoptosis
so I hope this was useful if you want to
get more notes and flashcards you can
follow us on Facebook or Instagram links
are provided in the description you can
support our Channel using super thanks
you can pay via paytm PayPal or UPI see
you in next video